all right thank you very much for my
volunteer today you may notice we're
going to be doing two short exercises
together because they are linked like
this so therefore I'll grow up too
quickly with these confirm whether we've
got right one answers and how we got
them
and they will move on okay so if you
have done watery questions you're
welcome to start driving down this and I
will get to in a couple business so
fiscarlos is how to look at number one
now you're asked to solve for all of
these questions so you can see there's a
pretty rule there but letter P you're
trying to find out the value that makes
this work write P outside people sign
equal the new 20 it slightly a very
useful for so what has happened from the
first night of the second line what's
going I can see two things that have
happened or if you're totally expanded
and then ultimately he added
page article slide has been stated here
within the right hand side having that
near you 20 of there is not helpful so
we add to a to both signs that makes the
right hand side zero and everything on
to the left once everything's on the
left it's not actually you can recognize
that you could say ah this is a
quadratic I can factorize it fairly
easily
people saw people spiral do it therefore
one of them has to be 0 or both
so one of them is negative vibes will
make that 0 as Megan is for weakness
hero various solutions there too when
you have a look at number 2 similar kind
of problems but it was more challenging
because I gave you something with a
number at the furni which wasn't one
just into a remembe R what is that cold
what that name is cool so for example
over here but they'll wrap in the catch
that P Square is just a 1 so we call
this and so the coefficient is 1 so we
call this banach here the copy is not 1
so we call it nod on them yeah but you
could call it Polly may be right there
is it always my phone it's both body
that means you have to work a little bit
harder to faster eyes but you can see
this side XY we've broken apart the
minus 7u is to minus 12 you and plus 5
you
why does would we do that while we split
it up and eat acres why is splitting of
the be highlighted for you just
occasionally following why is splitting
up - Evan you in - - twelve million plus
five you why is that or useful
we've uncollected life terms
we have we've broken it apart let it 12
you / 5 you looks like it this here not
better why is that improvement maybe
you're going to look and see what
happens on the next line by the way is
better plus missing there there we go
what's happened for the second lights of
the third line you can see more whites
and bad things up I could recognize a
common factor for Quinta you square and
minus 12 you let me set it again I could
recognize a common factor for 15 you
squared and plants of you have a look
what is the common factor it used it's
you and it's pretty so through you at
the same time once you pull that out
skew soon once you pull that out you can
see oh now I've got something dispatcher
don't forget by the way these are both
equal to 0 we've got equations going all
the way down so don't arm don't forget
the fact it is still an equation from an
app you've just got these bits
why would five you be equal to four why
would you pour that conclusion
like where does this even cover up I
don't see a five year for brace like
that yes
very good case you didn't quite catch
that
I've you have exactly right five you
motors fall is one of the factors well
if you've got two things well flow
together they give zero one of the
factors has to be zero
so here's a lot of them five year
boaters for if it's equal to zero and I
do suggest you add four to both sides
you want to get a business solution
alternatively it might not be that
backed up with zero what the other
background three years plus one if that
factor is equal to zero that you can see
you subtract one from both sides and
that gives you this and off you go
you've got your next solution okay
thumbs up and I've already done a check
of this one so well done I would just
think of mine a very very tiny note
where do you get equations which have T
in them which is actually quite common
I'm going to encourage you to put a tee
with a tail on it you'll want to suggest
why there might be a good idea because
it looks just like a plus side if you
don't and especially when you're in a
hurry in the exam you're like t plus the
big you know what am I even reading so I
encourage you to put a arm a tail on it
just so you can distinguish it's the
same reason why if you see is added a
question I tend to put the dash into it
so you don't mistake it for us to to